ray's lead the series
three games to one and they will have
john curtis on the mound for tampa bay
they're gonna go with the traditional
opener which they have
three times this season with john curtis
and you've got a guy
making his the biggest start of his
career luis garcia
but the career has been just a minute
he's a young guy he's excited about this
start
we're talking about a big arm can be a
little erratic with his secondary stuff
two and two the count on a rosarito and
he sends one to left field hits it hard
but right at tucker
and a couple of hard hit balls for out
george sprenger will start things off
for the astros in the first pitch and
sprinkler drills this one deep down the
left field line if it stays fair it's
gone
and that is a fair ball home run for
george bringer
his first lead off home run in the
postseason and the astros jump out to a
one-nothing lead
19 post-season home runs now for
springer
and the astros on the board first pitch
of the ball game you saw last night
springer loves
fastballs second most hits of 98 since
2017
and right here first pitch of the game
it's what dusty talks about with him
being the lead-off hitter
it's so dynamic and you see that he's
pointing up to gary pettis who's in the
stands
today their third base coach who it's so
good to see him in the stands
that just makes so that's gp and he
missed with it
and it's ball four and the bases are
loaded now
so here go the raise with a chance and
dusty baker
already second inning has decisions to
make
zunino in the air right field backing up
on it is
reddick at the track he's going to make
the catch
garcia now becomes the sixth different
lead-off man used by tampa bay this
postseason that is
a major league record and as far as
brandon
uh look he's gonna do he's gonna he's
gonna come up big for us
got a lot of confidence in brandon lau
he's gonna come up today with
some opportunity to do something do some
damage and find a hole find some grass
out there or maybe maybe find something
over the wall the one one pitch is
drilled
in the air to right center field doesn't
have enough get out of here
it is gone that might just get him going
brandon lau with his first home run of
the postseason
and the rays have tied this game at one
here on the third took it all the way to
the warning track first about with a lot
better swing than what we've seen
and now here 110.7 this was a no doubter
powered that one out of here and now for
the astros this is what they've been
waiting for
a couple guys on with the top of the
order and bradley will
drive in one for sure reddick scores
they're gonna wind up maldonado
throw to the plate one hops in and
maldonado is safe
a two rbi single michael bradley gives
the astros a three to one lead
grantley such a professional hitter
that's why he's hitting three for the
astros takes three
sinkers in an aggressive base running
set in maldonado
here's zanino he's dangerous got him
strike three with the high heat
zanino goes down and paradise
slams his fist into his glove and
prances back to the dugout a count to a
rose arena line hard to left and fanned
and the pitch there's a high drive into
right center field with springer
going back to the track to the wall he's
got another
home run a rose arena it's a one run
game
three to two houston number six of the
post season
for randy a rosarina tying evan longoria
for most home runs by rookie in a single
postseason not for the
raise but for all of baseball history
all i can do is smh
i just shake my head that they continue
to try to beat him with fastballs and
for that matter
continue to throw him strikes rosarina
cuban mookie bets
his manager calls him two and two the
count to margot the pitch
curve ball bounced softly left side
coming in bregman bare hands throws and
he got him
excellent play by bregman charging that
ball fielding it with the bare right
hand and getting it to first just ahead
of bargo who runs well one ball one
strike with two outs
one and two now incoming small dugouts
down here too so everybody's punched
together
andre scrub just got out of a jam
got it pretty good too being angry as a
pitcher works he's all right
all those rookie pitchers five in a row
used by dusty baker
all performing well holding the raise to
two runs
diaz on the ground under the glove but
right to l2v
and a low throw dug out by
what a play by the astros first baseman
and that's it for the raise here in the
seventh we'll go to the seventh inning
stretch
and trying to provide that noise and
that energy in the dugout teams have
done that in this
crowdless environment razer and familiar
territory these are the kind of games
they
seem to win the astros trying to hold
them off
and then balls hit high and deep seaman
choi will watch it fly
this game is tied at three
an absolute blast by g man choi
a no doubter into right field
his second home run of the postseason
and the rays have squared it at three a
piece
see the excitement for them ronnie said
this is the tight games they play now
all of a sudden they're tied
and he got to enjoy every second of that
one
that flip nice that's worthy of a bad
flip
g-man had a major bad flip there and
here is carlos correa
if carlos correa hits one out of here
you may see the
it might hit us up the world's longest
bat flip one ball
one strike in the air center field
correa is watching this is back and it's
gone
it's a walk off home run cardinals
correa
astros
has just forced a game six in this alcs
what a moment and their 71 year old
manager
is dancing the night away here in san
diego